зближення з європою у основного білянка
українську владу після майдану проти
кому стане урок і правда себе зубів я
за неї пророку в радикальній зміні за
сині експерти одна зграя не в тому ще
ближче step це не дивовижний результат
у досі таємних далося і європейським
політикам прийому ефірного українською
влада вмовляння з ними без прикладу chef
та он і на хід ще пізнання наземних
мобілу їжі ну видно нести ж тато
рідні та влада
ангіна але хто прання founded у нас
дався взнаки що нинішня реформа
головним china мати косметичний
характер науки не радикальні реформи
у сфері юстиції антикорупційні
реформи не проводиться науки дні реформи
в економіці так уже суд не
проекти і снують червоними невеликим навчанням
нафту або волосся жити антифон агентів і
аббас до морфіну що вона iphone початок
роботу зону винну тургіди сієста
пузатим виразку євро помістимо ці
рекомендую б зірку в режим з Україною
заснув не дуйся на якогось знайшли ходу
Європи просто на думку захисних політики
в ціни так і заслужено прямого
авансу збоку брюсселя
а мені ukraine а я витрачаю 2 2 в Україні
тіл уроку лупнув і не петлю ми то
президента порошенка хочу гулом ожив і
весь провести реформи бурити паску рубці
та й дуже важливо
even знаючи процес агентств спілкуюсь з
григорієм по позику ногу і відкриття
українського або європейського ринку на
перших етапах вигравати інші
економіки крил поважають експерти ls
годину [ __ ] ківі чого її україна авось
та базі візовий режим цяо прямо вчинках
його збоку брюсселем особливо над чи на
старі в парі хижих європейців тут
скіс щура та біженці поважають аналітики
зовсім не всі храми діана європейського
союзу народити чоловікові його муза проварюю
безвізового режиму з україною путін на
політичному рівні та їжі screens
пряма цикл плакала
на повторі ось і помовчи porsche до
майдану і не смирнова ти новий шанс для
випорожнень змін України
процес постійно перебувати із захист
готовий до допомоги баржа не проводьте
реформи
травні бути заспівом випереджають експерти
авансі з боку заходу більше не буде